the psychedelics are safe if done
correctly and they're safe that dose is
so terrifying that you would never want
to do more the danger with psychedelics
is not death
the danger is madness obviously if these
things can't kill you I mean it would be
a terrible way to commit suicide because
it wouldn't work but what they do is
they hurl you against the wall of your
assumptions and then jump on you and rub
your nose in it and stomp on you and
make you want to die and make you beg
freedom not always but they can do that
and so it's very important when you get
in there that you can at least have the
pharmacological facts under your belt so
you can explain to yourself what's going
on for instance it amazes me I've heard
this story maybe a dozen times of people
taking mushrooms which they either grew
or bought taking mushrooms and then an
hour or 40 minutes into it deciding
quote-unquote that these are obviously
not psilocybin mushrooms these are
poisonous emotions and now they're going
to die well that's shows you just don't
have your mind under control you know
you need to have a talk with yourself
about your tendency to give hysterical
and tight situations
because you're not dying you you have to
come to the place where you can actually
turn to the whining eco and say you are
dying me I'm going further but you're
dying that's your right
death death death roll in its citizens
and and and and discipline the mind
because the ego does not want you to
take psychedelics the voice which tells
you not to take psychedelics is the
voice of your ego it says look we've got
a lot to lose professional position to
think of ok and then if you resist and
go to the next level it plays the next
days you know you're crazy you know that
you're not like these other people
you're crazy you should stay away from
it and then if all else fails it plays
the final race you're dying dying and
they're called 911 too
you know I had a friend who got into
that position and who called 911
ambulance came and they took him away
and naturally these psychedelic crises
are usually fairly short-lived so by the
time he was had attention in the
emergency room it was all passed and he
said to the doctor who God bless this
doctor he must have been quite hip the
guy said and he said he said did this
did the mushroom cause this and the guy
said well I don't see how the mushroom
could cause it we see panic attack cases
in here every day and I never had one
caused by a month
[Laughter]
[Music]
you